>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
THE VIOLENT GANG MS-13
UNLEASHING NEW HAVOC.
THIS TIME IN HOUSTON.
POLICE SAY THEY ARRESTED A
MEMBER AFTER HE KIDNAPPED A
14-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
THE SUSPECT LED THEM ON A
HIGH-SPEED CHASE ACROSS AN
INTERSTATE.
THIS HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
WENT ON FOR 30 MILES.
DIDN'T END UP IN THE SUSPECT RAN
OUT OF GAS AND SURRENDERED.
POLICE SAY THE KIDNAPPED VICTIM
WAS NOT IN THE CAR DURING THE
CHASE AND IS OKAY.
CRITICS CLAIM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS TARGETING
MS-13 TO DEMONIZE IMMIGRANTS FOR
IMPORTING CRIME.
STATISTICS DO NOT LIE.
HERE'S WHAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SAYS.
THERE'S NOW 10,000 MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS IN THE UNITED STATES.
NEW REPORTING BY "THE WASHINGTON
POST" OVER THE WEEKEND REVEALS
HOW MS-13 IS ESSENTIALLY TAKING
OVER ONE HIGH SCHOOL IN SUFFOLK
COUNTY, NEW YORK.
THE GANG HAS COMMITTED 27
MURDERS IN THE AREA, ALL SINCE
THE ILLEGAL MINORS BEGAN
ARRIVING IN 2013.
JOINING US NOW, A MAN ON THE
FRONT LINES OF MS-13, JAY LAMB.
HE'S BEEN GREAT ON RADIO.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE NORTHERN
REGIONAL TASK FORCE.
JAY, THE "WASHINGTON POST" IS
LIKE FINALLY REALLY ON TO THIS.
THEY'RE REPORTING ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN LONG ISLAND, WHICH
IS STUNNING.
A PARENT OF A YOUNG WOMAN WHO
WAS MURDERED BY MS-13 TWO YEARS
AGO CAME ON OUR SHOW RECENTLY.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> I'M FEELING THE LOSS OF MY
DAUGHTER.
I FEEL IT EVERY DAY.
THERE'S NOT A DAY, A SECOND THAT
I DON'T THINK ABOUT MY DAUGHTER.
AND THEY JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE PAIN OF A PARENT LOSING
THEIR CHILD TO THIS GANG
VIOLENCE.
>> THAT WAS A MOM, EVELYN
RODRIGUEZ.
TELL US, THESE WERE MIDDLE
CLASS, FAIRLY SAFE COMMUNITIES.
WHEN I MOVED HERE IN 1986.
IT'S A DIFFERENT WORLD NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE INFLUX OF THESE GANG
MEMBERS, MS-13 IN THE NORTHERN
VIRGINIA AREA HAS JUST
OVERWHELMED THE RESOURCES IN THE
AREA.
THE VIOLENT CRIME IS UNHEARD OF
UNLIKE WHAT ANYONE WOULD EXPECT
TO EVER SEE.
THE VIOLENCE WITH MACHETES.
>> Laura: MACHETES?
>> THAT'S THEIR WEAPON OF FORCE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE BRUTALITY
THAT EXPOSES TO THE BODY.
>> WHEN YOU SEE THE RESULTS OF
THIS OPEN BORDERS, ALLOWING
THESE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS IN
THE UNITED STATES, WE HAVE 5,000
JUST IN THE NEW YORK AREA, 5,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
AS YOU POINTED OUT BEFORE,
THEY'RE PRIME TARGETS FOR MS-13
RECRUITING, ARE THEY NOT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE'VE SEEN THAT THE LAST TWO TO
THREE YEARS AND THE AMOUNT OF
VIOLENT CRIME BEING COMMITTED BY
JUVENILES, WHICH WE DIDN'T USED
TO SEE.
THERE'S BEEN SO MANY KIDS THAT
HAVE COME INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE SCARED TO DEATH, PUT IN
SCHOOLS.
SOME OF THEM DON'T READ AND
WRITE.
>> Laura: IN THEIR OWN LANGUAGE,
THANK YOU.
>> THE GANG MEMBERS KNOW THIS,
THEY PREY UPON THEM, EXPLOIT THE
WEAKNESSES, LACK OF A FAMILY
STRUCTURE, RELATIONSHIP ISSUES.
THEY EXPLOIT ALL OF IT.
>> ONLY 4% OF THE MINORS THAT
HAVE COME IN DURING THE OBAMA
WAVE, ONLY 4% HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED.
WHEN THIS HAPPENED, YOU REMEMBER
WHAT OBAMA SAID.
YOU CANNOT STAY HERE.
THAT WAS HIS COMMENT BUT
EVERYBODY STAYS HERE.
SO WE HAVE THOUSANDS ON
THOUSANDS OF MINORS ROLLING
AROUND THE UNITED STATES, SOME
WITH SPONSORS, SOME WITH NOT.
NOT ALL OF THESE ARE GANG
MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY.
LET ME SHOW YOU WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN TEXAS WITH THIS
HIGH-SPEED CHASE.
THE TEXAS PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMISSION HAS LISTED THE MOST
LETHAL GANGS IN TEXAS.
THIS IS LAST JULY.
THE REPORT THAT CAME OUT.
HERE THEY ARE.
TANGO BLAST, ANOTHER GANG, THE
LATIN KINGS, BEEN AROUND FOR
YEARS.
TEXAS MEXICAN MAFIA.
AND MS-13.
OKAY.
MS-13 IS NUMBER 4.
DEADLY BECAUSE OF THE CARTEL
MEMBERSHIP AND THE CARTEL
CONNECTION TO THESE GANGS.
TELL US WHY THAT DRIVES THE
VIOLENCE.
>> WELL, MS-13 STARTED BECAUSE
THEY WERE PROTECTING THEMSELVES
FROM THE MEXICAN MAFIA.
NOW THEY WORKED WITH THE MEXICAN
MAFIA BECAUSE THE CARTELS ARE
PUSHING THE DRUGS ACROSS THE
BORDER AND THEY'RE WORKING
TOGETHER, MEXICAN MAFIA, MS-13
AND OUTLAW MOTORCYCLE GANGS TO
DISTRIBUTE THE DRUGS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: SO DRUGS ARE A HUGE
PART OF THIS.
HOW BIG IS HUMAN TRAFFIC
SOMETHING.
>> IT'S LARGE.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE.
MOST OF THE GIRLS INVOLVED ARE
BRAINWASHED AND THEY DON'T SEE
THEMSELVES AS VICTIMS.
IT'S A HARD CASE TO PROSECUTE
AND TO INVESTIGATE BECAUSE OF
THAT REASON.
>> Laura: HOW DO THE POLICE WHO
MANY TIMES ARE UNDERSTAFFED,
OVERWORKED, UNDERPAID AND GOING
UP AGAINST ONE OF THE MOST
BRUTAL GANGS IN THE WORLD, NOT
JUST -- IN THE WORLD.
>> IT'S DIFFICULT.
>> Laura: SO RIDICULOUS THIS IS
HAPPENING.
THESE BEAUTIFUL PARTS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
SUFFOLK COUNTY, BEDROOM
COMMUNITY IN NEW YORK, NORTHERN
VIRGINIA, MARYLAND.
THIS IS LIKE MIDDLE CLASS SAFE
COMMUNITIES.
>> IT'S A FACT, MS-13 IS THE
FASTEST GROWING GANG IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PROPENSITY FOR VIOLENCE IS
VERY HIGH.
>> Laura: AND BY THE WAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED THEM OUT